olá o que eu vim contar pra vocês não é
nada épico não é nenhum grande projeto
ou ideia ou algo que vai mudar um
paradigma daqui 15 minutos o tempo que
vou ficar aqui conversando com vocês a
minha falha muito mais sobre um processo
uma descoberta algo que ao mesmo tempo
que eu venho estudando teorizando e
analisando é a mesma coisa que eu venho
sentindo experienciando e percebendo na
minha vida e tudo começa quando eu
especialista mas também representante da
geração y essa geração que vai gerir vai
cuidar do mundo num futuro bem próximo
me dei conta de duas coisas primeiro que
eu sou o que eu posso e eu devo ser
comum e 2 que pensar num plano de
aposentadoria planejar o passado o meu
eo do mundo porque no momento em que eu
comecei a me dar conta disso na minha
vida nos meus estudos
eu me encontro vocês podem estar se
dando que isso vai contra três das
principais características que os
especialistas atribuem pra geração isso
a primeira de que a gente se acha
especial a segunda de que a gente só
trabalho só faz as coisas que nos dão
prazer ou aquilo que a gente gosta ea
terceira de que somos consumistas e o
que a gente possui já nos representa
para o mundo e os especialistas estão
certos e mais certos ainda quando eles
dizem que talvez sejam esses três pontos
dos pontos atribuídos pela frustração
que essa geração vem sentindo a minha
descoberta o meu aprendizado é que
exatamente quando a gente se diverte
cada um desses três códigos quando a
gente hackeia e desconstrói essas
características que a gente consegue
achar o potencial das coisas dos
projetos dos ambientes e quem sabe de
nós mesmos
então eu convido todo mundo a ser hacker
seja da geração y ou não pra gente
subverter o primeiro código que é de se
sentir especial quando a gente desce do
pedestal
antes de tudo a gente faz as pazes com o
mundo e com a gente mesmo porque
primeiro às expectativas que o mundo tem
que a gente tem a gente mesmo terminando
então a gente pode errar a gente pode
pedir ajuda a gente pode experimentar a
gente pode dizer que a gente não sabe
mas o mais bonito pra mim quando a gente
desce do pedestal
a gente faz esse movimento é que a gente
deixa de exigir do mundo esperado mundo
reconhecimento
a gente deixa de esperar dos outros
atenção conforto e facilidade
a gente deixa de achar que é dever do
outro o nosso bem estar e com isso vem
muita responsabilidade porque no momento
em que eu me vejo como uma pessoa comum
tem um senso de comunidade também e aí
eu me vejo dentro de um grupo eu vejo
que ao mesmo tempo que eu sou livre eu
também sou totalmente independente do
outro porque o outro é totalmente
dependente de mim quando a gente vai
para o segundo código que é de só fazer
eu só trabalhar com aquilo que a gente
gosta que ele é o nosso talento que nos
dá prazer
antes de tudo isso não existe eu acho
porque hoje em dia principalmente é
muito difícil a gente se sintonizar com
a nossa voz interna tem tanto ruído
tanta geração de desejo tanto a criação
de expectativa ao nosso redor que é
difícil a gente saber o que a gente quer
eu tive uma experiência na vida eu
estava há alguns anos atrás alguns anos
planejando dentro já de uma carreira né
prosperando
mas se sente uma frustração que não tava
entendendo que ela não fazia muito
sentido para quem vinha de fora mas eu
precisei ter a coragem de mexer tá nesse
sistema pra tentar entender o que estava
acontecendo e foi nesse momento de que
mg they que a frustração eo alívio não
saíram mas eu tive um alívio só que ao
mesmo tempo me vi num vazio era como se
tivesse tido uma corrida atrás da
lâmpada mágica eu tivesse encontrado
esfregado gênios aí se perguntar se o
que você quer agora você está livre e eu
não sabia o que dizer
eu juro que eu queria ter tipo aquele
sonho dentro de mim agora é a hora que
eu posso ser cantora que foi sempre o
meu sonho não eu sempre quis e bióloga
essa é a hora ou não eu vou estudar
mandarim e dá a volta no mundo porque é
isso que agora eu posso fazer
mas não nada daquilo que a pt cia
e aí a minha grande descoberta e
aprendizado e o que eu venho aprendendo
é que não é negando o sistema não é
negando o que a gente não gosta não é
saindo de um extremo indo pro outro
saindo de um rótulo e achando o rótulo
que vai compensar aquele que eu tava mas
sim com muita generosidade coragem a
gente
entrar o sistema adentrar o comum
ordinário o normal que quando a gente
faz isso a gente passa a aprender como
ele funciona e aí a gente tem
conhecimento e poder para desconstruir
para subverter e quando a gente tem boas
intenções essas peças desse sistema que
a gente se diverte
a gente consegue reconstruir e fazer o
nosso microssistema a gente pode mudar
nossa rotina nossa forma de se
relacionar com as pessoas e por a gente
viver numa rede numa grande engrenagem
por agente desconstroem nosso mundinho
ea gente começa a reconstruir com boas
intenções automaticamente as peças que
estão ao nosso redor começam a se auto
configurar sozinha de forma orgânica e
automática e isso começa a reverberar
quando a gente vai para o terceiro
código então para sermos atores e
desconstruí lo é sobre o consumo
eu não acho que é errado consumir pra
mim isso não é saudável quando a gente
consome ea começa a acumular coisas para
usar como armaduras pro mundo sejam elas
armaduras visuais das coisas que eu
possuo que eu tenho elas falam para o
mundo que eu como eu quero que o mundo
me veja mas também quando elas são
armaduras emocionais quando trocar
dinheiros por coisas passa a ser algo
que vai suprir carências que eu tenho o
que vai tapar minhas vulnerabilidades
que são tão essenciais para o meu
crescimento
e aí eu também tive uma experiência bem
legal que foi quando eu saí de uma
grande metrópole foi morar em outro país
numa cidade menor que eu fui rever como
era minha rotina porque naquela fase de
readaptação a gente tenta se apegar às
coisas que são básicas que o nosso bem
estar
eu comecei ainda conta que muitas das
coisas com as quais eu gostava dinheiro
eram pra compensar a hábitos e padrões
que eu nunca tinha me questionado mas
que achava que eram básicos quanto eu
tinha que gastar com a academia cara
para compensar 10 horas que eu ficava
sentado na frente do computador dentro
de uma empresa no ar condicionado
o quanto eu tinha que gastar com médico
remédio para curar minha gastrite mas
quem estava se alimentando e se
expressando mal era eu mesma o quanto o
que eu tinha que gastar com roupa nova
porque eu não queria repetir roupa mas
era eu que ia sempre nos mesmos lugares
encontrar as mesmas pessoas o quanto eu
gostava
tempo e economizar dinheiro para minhas
férias mirabolantes quando era eu mesmo
que passava 11 meses do ano talvez
trabalhando com coisas e cansando coisas
que não me inspiravam e aí fazer esse
exercício é muito interessante porque
não é pra cortar custo não é pra
diminuir o orçamento e só consequência
na verdade pra gente ver que uma vida
mais consciente mais simples mas mais
minimalista ela pode ser muito mais rica
abundante e eficiente porque quando a
gente fazia isso a gente se liberta fica
tão mais leve e desapegado e aí
agilidade para a gente se locomover e
como se movimentar por novos projetos
novas experiências e novos lugares
é muito mais fácil a moeda nesse sistema
é outra
então quando eu comecei a me dar conta
que eu podia quebrar esses padrões sobre
mim mesma e que era nessas horas que a
tinha sofrimento mas era onde eu mais me
sentia realizada eu comecei a perceber
que começava a surgir um novo estilo de
vida eram esses novos valores que de
alguma forma sempre revise tava na hora
de tomar as grandes e as pequenas
decisões da minha vida do dia-a-dia eram
esses os valores que me ajudavam afinal
meu olhar pra eu ter o espírito aguçado
para reconhecer atraiu criar as
oportunidades que eu queria abraçar e
eram esses os valores que eu começava a
entender que me davam duas métricas e
indicadores sobre que é sucesso e é uma
pessoa de sucesso um projeto de sucesso
ou qq é a noção de riqueza que é alguma
coisa ou alguém ser rico e aí quando eu
comecei a ver que esse estilo de vida
estava se configurando na minha frente
eu comecei a perceber também que eu
estava ficando mais ética mais estética
mas processual e mais ecológica
mas não porque era moda não porque é uma
ideologia uma banheira uma bandeira ou
um rótulo novo mas sim porque é assim
que o jogo funciona é premissa é
conseqüência
no momento em que começa a viver de
acordo com esses valores
eu fico mais ética eu fico mais ética
porque eu entendo a autonomia ea
independência dos elementos por mais que
o meio e as pessoas não estejam no mesmo
jogo
no momento em que eu entendo que é sendo
mais tranqüila
mas responsável é pensando e não
compensando eu me dou conta que as
coisas ficam muito mais fáceis e muito
mais gratificantes tirar vantagem desse
sistema é só desperdício de energia de
tempo porque olha eu vou estar pensando
e confabulando como tirar vantagem de
alguém
ora eu vou estar sempre na defensiva e
desconfiada porque alguém vai estar
tirando vantagem de mim e me torna mais
10 e mais estética e mais processual
porque aqui mais do que valorizar um
produto final uma chegada a gente acaba
por valorizar a beleza do processo
aqui a gente adiciona uma quarta
dimensão a cada palavra falada cada
palavra escutada a cada projeto a cada
caminhada cada coisa e essa dimensão é o
tempo e não a velocidade do tempo mas
sim o tempo como o processo com uma
história quando a gente olha cada coisa
e tenta entender o porquê o como ela
chegou até ali a gente abre caminho para
a inovação para a criatividade para a
colaboração ea gente se torna mais
ecológico porque hoje quando tem alguma
dúvida a gente vai direto para o google
mas a tecnologia mais avançada ea
natureza são quatro com 5 bilhões de
anos de tentativa e teste de acerto e
erro a natureza ea tecnologia mais
avançada ea biblioteca e se a gente está
falando natureza em transformação e
evolução ela já nos ensina é o ambiente
que determina quem é ou quem vai
sobreviver e talvez essa seja a dica que
eu nova sim mas posso passar para vocês
porque isso que eu venho experimentando
vivendo hoje que é se a gente realmente
quer fazer algum tipo de mudança ou
traçar um novo caminho é se colocando em
ambientes que vão nos testar nos
estimular nos colocar em prova e como
geração y dói dizer mas em ambientes que
vão nos tirar da zona de conforto e sair
da zona de conforto não é só tomar essa
decisão falar e num click a zona de
conforto sai da nossa frente a gente tem
um novo filme para viver na verdade é
uma troca de um sentimento de frustração
mas que tem previsibilidade conforto por
um conjunto de sentimentos de muita mão
na massa vulnerabilidade
responsabilidade mas muita realização e
não é mudando de trabalho
mudando de cidade que a gente vai forçar
essa decisão
essa decisão precisa ser sentidas
estimulada foi decidida todo dia quando
a gente coloca o dente mudar de são
paulo para miami ou sair de los angeles
para ir morar no interior de minas
gerais dentro de um museu e só parte de
uma escolha o que vale é a gente decidir
que tipo de estímulo que tipo de pessoas
que tipo de experiência a gente está
disposto a viver neste momento a gente
jamais a decisão porque no momento que a
gente ama as nossas decisões
a gente ganha um pacote de prazeres e de
problemas e esse pacote de problemas e
prazeres no momento em que a gente ama a
gente carrega uma mochila nesses
caminhos e eles deixam de ter conotações
positivas ou negativas
eles só aparecem como oportunidades para
agente interagir para a gente aprender
pra gente ensinar para a gente ter novas
histórias para contar pra gente fazer
novos amigos porque é nesse momento em
que a gente ama nossos prazeres e
problemas que a gente permite que ele
nos dê modifiquem a gente modifiquem o
difícil nesses ambientes as pessoas com
as quais a gente conversa encontra no
caminho por isso que pensar num plano de
aposentadoria para mim não faz muito
sentido porque como eu vou investir
agora recurso energia num pacote de
problemas e prazeres que eu só vou viver
daqui umas décadas
na verdade o problema não é a
aposentadoria mas se esse gap que existe
entre o que eu desejo agora entre o que
eu planejo islam bru e um momento em que
eu vou viver e aí foi quando me dei
conta disso que eu comecei a criar a
viver e eu fui contemplada com o meu
plano de aposentada que amy retirar
desses padrões a fim de encontrar o meu
bem estar de forma bem genuína eu
acredito que quando eu faço esse
movimento automaticamente está
reverberando isso para quem está comigo
eu estou exigindo isso de quem está
comigo isso vai transformar pra vocês
para os outros e como resultado a gente
vai ter o bem comum
muito obrigada